a devastating discovery has been made in
canada
the remains of 215 children have been
found buried at the site of a former
boarding school for indigenous students
the school in british columbia was part
of a nationwide scheme that took in
first nations children
in an effort to assimilate them into
canadian society
investigations have shown there was
widespread abuse
these latest findings are once again
opening a wound that has yet to heal
row upon row of children's shoes each
pair
marking a lost son or daughter in
vancouver people gathered to mourn the
215 children
whose remains were found at a former
indigenous residential school
with ground penetrating radar confirming
the grim discovery
it was shocking at every single level
and you know right now you know our
community is grieving
we all had to um take time to
absorb you know what we were told what
we've seen
and um you know we're we're still
grappling through the effects
founded in 1890 the kamloops school was
one of canada's state-run indigenous
residential schools
after being forcibly separated from
their parents children were made to
convert to christianity
and banned from speaking their native
languages
physical and sexual abuse by headmasters
and teachers was common
a 2015 report found that over 3 200
children had died from maltreatment
and neglect in what it called a cultural
genocide
the kamloops school closed in 1978 but
rumors persisted
that the deaths of many children had
been covered up canada's politicians
including prime minister justin trudeau
said they were heartbroken by the news
there's nothing more painful in life
than losing a child
my heart breaks today thinking of all
the loving parents
who never saw their children return home
the tekemlaps to sequette magnation says
it's working with the coroner and
museums
to try to shed light on the discovery
and find records of the children's
deaths
you